we got Austin Barrett this is Austin
praise God brother Austin from Nebraska
got a king of sting it for you cliff
jumping in jeans boo in jeans
damn that's gangster Wow great video
shout out to Nebraska where is he in
Kuala Lumpur where was yeah he's in
Nebraska Oh Nebraska no way that
correctly uh cliff jump in from using me
a heart Pass I did in college at Table
Rock in Missouri and it's a place where
everyone jumped off as the middle of the
summer right and so all my friends are
there so you take a boat there and I was
like that's not that high like really
you're doing like y'all do it we hike up
there it's high it once you get up there
yes so high I didn't want to do it all
my friends jumped in like damn I do not
want to do this and then some drunk dude
I'm like getting ready to go and there's
ice trying to impress these girls and
the guys on the boat with the girls goes
John Paul sir I thought I I thought it
was you dude I jump your boy belly flop
hit my face contact when everywhere
water my ear awful experience never do
it your eye open when you [ __ ] lame
no it forced a boom contact boom you
gotta have stronger eye oh yeah you're
right it's not for me I brushed it need
to be stronger but listen for your
eyelids you got to be especially valid I
think so let me see clean eyes no no
don't do that I'll squint just close
them there you go yeah and close your
mouth too when you do it this just close
your eyes I'm a tenured a close your
eyes like you changed a lot oh do you
know I did before I went home I'm not
afraid to admit this that to use a
little bit of just for men I thought
about you you ever use just for men just
for men for when outside my tinder
profile I can hair off
no it's for
your hair is a little brush excited all
these Gracie I'm like damn I was like
these gray hair stress so I just put a
little little color there dog tell me
can't even tell right my mom likes I'm
girl my hair out yeah let's go min and
she said she said she groped like whew I
said mom he was born with that haircut
or it's a wig we don't know Shh it's a
wig but but it's don't do one of my
parent they said that TV show honey
booboo and one of my favorite things
they had a store in their town called
it's a wig well Austin I think that's
great man if you can be that you know if
you got that kind of resiliency and your
body and stuff like that in your body
can handle hitting the water like that
did I remember doing a 60 footer when I
was young did you grow up doing that nor
do I stop doing it they had a guy named
Jeff in our town who jumped off of this
is probably 95 feet dude off of an
overpass in interstate and hit a [ __ ]
boat he didn't see that a boat was
coming by and fine what happened right
into that best dude shattered shattered
one of his legs
no lived shattered one of his uh fibulas
or something Tim Ulis and you guys
stopped doing it and he was never the
same
actually he was never the same really
before it I don't think he was never he
was never after he hit that Bodi we all
signed a reason after he hit that boat
you know now I'm crazy people don't
there's a boat you know and he still
went dude if you do this Husker Tarzan
and keep jumping off the [ __ ] cliffs
do it man yeah this day it's not for me
woody could you do that can you do that
yeah yeah and I see see and you guys
think I'm being mean I don't wanna be
racist I'm just gonna say can you swim I
could swim okay all right I just don't
like the water
oh dude a lot of black guys and they get
in the water they get violent against it
yeah you
yeah yeah it's like they win the first
round that win the second round to live
there I call it the deep water rap dude
Elijah had to come get me in Huntington
Beach
I got stuck yeah can you swim right now
yes man
I'm just curious some guys can't swim
Dee can you swim you can't swim bro tell
me your bill like my brother he can't
swim or [ __ ] yeah that floating [ __ ] is
hard it's tough that doggy paddle spot
is hard cat can you swim yeah can you
swim - Jenkins swim don't be like yeah
oh wow yeah okay I'm not the only one
but yes women yes what makes this
swimming on make me nervous a little bit
I love it man I look like a seal in the
ocean
[Music]
the King nothing
[Music]